So let's look back at
the TMDBClient.swift file.
There are two commented methods in
this file called taskForGETMethod and
taskForPOSTMethod.
The goals of these methods is to take
the duplicate code that exists for
the GET request the the POST requests
that we're making to the movie database
and moving them here.
Now, you could create different
methods for this goal.
They don't have to be called
taskForGETMethod and taskForPOSTMethod.
Those were just some names that
we chose for this example.
Now you could even split these
methods taskForGETMethod and
taskForPOSTMethod into smaller methods,
each specialized for
a different part of
making a network task.
So maybe building the URL,
making the task and then you
could have something that checks the
errors and I'd highly encourage that.
But for now, we're just going to
work with these two methods.
I'm going to delete these real quick and
use them as a way of giving you an idea
of how this kind of process works.
How this process of better
architecturing our apps work.
Because at the end of the day,
what we're really trying to accomplish
here is better design of our code.
And if you talk to ten different
developers, you might get ten different
ideas about what better design is,
but that's kind of another topic.
For now, let's just focus on what
these methods take as parameters and
what they return, so that we can
work on this specific example.
Each method takes a string
parameter called method.
The intent of this parameter is to
represent the API method that should be
used by the request.
So remember these are things like,
what was it, authentication,
validate with token or slash account.
These were the methods
that we're talking about,
then our second parameter for lack of
a better word is called parameters and
it's a variable parameter and it takes
any of the parameters that we want to
specify in the URL such as the ApIKey.
These are things that go in
the query portion of the URL.
Next, for the taskForPOSTMethod,
we have this extra parameter that's not
included in taskForGET called jsonBody.
And of course, this parameter allows
us to pass in values into the HTTP body
of a post request and
we'll look at it more later.
Now, the last parameter is where these
two methods get really interesting.
Both methods end with
a closure parameter
called a completionHandlerForGET
in this case and
completionHandlerForPOST in
the taskForPOSTMethod.
Now remember,
a closure is just a block of code.
If you need a refresher on closures,
I recommend that you go back and
watch the SWF syntax section
that we have on closures.
Now these closures that we've
called completion handlers, they're
very similar to the completion handlers
that you seen before when we used
the NSURLSessionDataTask for request and
we can look an example at over here.
Remember, those completion handlers,
they had the data, response and
error parameters and these completion
handlers aren't run until the data task
itself completes and
then it executes this block of code.
These things are very
similar here on the left.
These completion handlers very similar,
but
the signature is just
a little bit different.
These completion handlers take result,
which could be AnyObject and
an optional NSError and
a return void or nothing.
We're going to use these completion
handlers to pass back the resulting data
from our network requests in the result
parameter or if an error happens for
our request, then we'll pass back back
the error in the error parameter.
If that was hard to follow,
then let's pause and
let's take a look at
the taskFor GetImageMethod.
It's already implemented and
it has a similar completion handler,
it's called
completionHandlerForImage and
it's going to look very much like
what we'll do for these two methods.
So, let's take a look
at this one real quick.
So in this method,
we start by building the URL,
so we can make a network request for
some image.
Keep scrolling, there we go.
It makes the request and then
the completion handler for the request,
it starts with our series of guard
statements to make sure that there was
no error and then assuming all
these guard statements pass,
then it calls
the completionHandlerForImage.
And it passes the resulting data,
the imageData and because there was no
error, it passes nil for the error and
then it calls the resume method for
the task to make sure it runs and
then we return the network task.
Now the network task being returned
here is just an implementation detail,
don't worry about that for now.
Let's focus on this call to
the completionHandlerForImage.
This line of code, it calls the closure
that's passed Into taskForGETImage.
It's calling this closure.
So, let's see what this looks like
if we're call taskForGETImage.
It's going to make this make
a lot more sense, I think.
Now back in our loginViewController,
let's pretend that I want to
call taskForGETImage.
So to call this, I'm going to specify
some phony size and file path and
then we'll get to the
completionHandlerForImage closure part.
Now, this is where we get a real
opportunity to see the power of
closures.
Here where I'm calling taskForGetImage,
I want to specify what I want to
happen when this task completes.
Closure, which we've specified
as a trailing closure,
it has access to the imageData and
any error that may have occurred and
you can get rid of Void here.
If you think about it, this is the exact
same behavior that we want with our
taskForGETMethod and taskForPOSTMethod.
Inside of our view controller, so this
is our loginViewController remember,
we want to be able to make
our request using the client.
So that TMDB client's being used and
then when the request completes,
we can use the resulting data or
the error in the view controller.
And this helps reduce the complexity
of our view controllers,
because it puts all of
the networking code into the client.
We don't see any networking code here.
We just see the tasks that we're
wanting to call and we see, hey,
we're going to get some data back or
some error back.
What do you want to do with it?
So from the perspective
of the view controller,
we don't really care how
the networking works.
We just want to know are there
results or was there an error and
then we can handle those
cases appropriately.
So that was a lot to take in, so
let's just pause for a second.
If you need to take a deep breath,
if you need to go back and
rewatch this video from the beginning,
feel free.
When you're ready to move forward,
we're going to get started
with tasksForGETMethod and
it's going to look a lot like this
taskForGETImage in the sense that it's
going to allow our view controllers
to just make the call and
then have our completion handler,
our closure here,
specify what we want to
do with the results.